السودان له التجارب طويله في الانتقال
يعني بعد الاستقلال كان هنالك انتقال بعد
ثوره اكتوبر كان هنالك انتقال كان هنالك
انتقال طويل بعد 2005 بعد اتفاقيه السلام
الشامل
ولذلك هذه التجارب كان ينبغي ان لا تهدر
من سوء الحظ انه كثير من رموز السياسيه
والفكريه التي كانت تقود الاحزاب وتقود
المعارضه وبعضهم كان حتى في السلطه من
قاده الحركه الاسلاميه كانوا يمثلون
مستودع للحكمه ولكن مع التغيير غالي في
هذه الشخصيات غابت بالموتى الطبيعي اغلبهم
وبعضهم بالتقدم العمر
فتصدت للقياده بعد الثوره اجيال شابه
عندها تجارب محدوده ولذلك انا دعوت اول ما
دعوت انه الثورات كلها تحتاج الى قيمه
اسمها التسامح السودان يحتاج الى مصالحه
ضخمه مصالحه كتل ليس فقط بين الدعم السريع
والجيش ولكن اقاليم باكملها في السودان
الحرب الاهليه
غاليهمت منذ منذ البدايه الان هنالك جدل
عن ادماج الحركات الجيوش الدعم السريع في
الجيش وهذه تجربه في العالم كله موجوده
يعني وفيها حلول وافكار ورؤى وتفاصيل فنيه
يمكن ان نصل الى حل ولكن البعض اللي هي
انه كيف يمكن ان نجد صيقه نحدد بها كيف
يحكم السودان هذا الخلاف منذ الاستقلال ما
زال قائما نريد ان نمضي الانتخابات ولكن
ليس لنا احزاب تاسست على الديمقراطيه يمكن
ان تخوض شرط اساسي من التحول الديمقراطي